former Teen Mom 2 star Jenelle Evans is
still facing serious backlash after her
husband David Eason seemingly admitted
to shooting and killing her dog nugget
Jenelle has reportedly been barred from
visits with her nine-year-old son Jace
who is in the custody of Jenelle's
mother Barbara Jenelle's four-year-old
son Kaiser was also reportedly removed
from her home by Child Protective
Services on May 10th and is currently
staying with his father Nathan Griffith
as for Jenelle's two-year-old daughter
enslie whom she shares with David she is
reportedly still in the home reports
state Child Protective Services launched
an investigation after allegations that
David shot and killed their French
Bulldog nugget didn't get he should be
grew he all but confirmed this claiming
the family pet attacked Ensley in a
since deleted video of the dog appearing
aggressive writing I'm all about
protecting my family it is my life's
mission some people are worth killing or
dying for and my family means that much
to me
Jenelle shared a tribute to nugget
writing in part nugget I'm crying
everyday I love you so much and I'm so
sorry I'm speechless
you're gone forever and there's no
coming back following the news MTV cut
ties with Jenelle and explained in a
statement to ET that they have quote no
plans to cover her story in the upcoming
season a source told ET that it came as
an unpleasant surprise to the reality
star this is David MTV previously ended
their relationship with David in
February 2018 after he posted a number
of homophobic and transphobic tweets
[Music]
as for the couple's future together our
source says they are still an item and
Janelle has been telling close friends
they are considering marriage counseling
et has reached out to a rep for the
couple for comment
[Music]